what's happening in his match against
liam lee and in the game we are
following prague could be about to tie
the match against hans niemann
i guess it's getting quite close and
look at that the clocks as well
ticking but
price seems to be in control he's in
full control and uh he should be winning
any moment now
um i still love the fact that nieman is
fighting or credit to him he's setting
some traps here and there prague has had
to show some accuracy at least at the
end
but now i mean i'm trying to calculate
you could have captured black's rook you
could have captured black's bishop as
prague does and the pawn probably yeah
you can capture the pawn yeah it's all
winning now
and uh the problem is the black knight
is attacked
and
he just lets it drop
and there we go white is a piece up and
neiman resigns
it's over for hans niemann young
pregnant he ties the match against the
american who won the first game but
prague
cool customers striking back as he
always does to tie the match